[Inaudible].
You talk specifically about the symptoms, cause we're hearing some,
some conflicting information on that and then about the transmission part,
because I think that's where people are most worried at the most.
So the symptoms are going to be just like any cold or flu that you get.
They're going to be cough, fever, sore throat, maybe a runny nose,
maybe a little bit of GI symptoms, meaning nausea and vomiting,
maybe some diarrhea.
And then shortness of breath is the one that we worry about in terms of
pneumonia. Those are the main symptoms and they overlap a lot with influenza.
The contagiousness is that this is a disease that's pretty contagious compared
to other Corona viruses like SARS and MERS, which were scary,
but not very contagious between people.
This is behaving more like the other Corona viruses that cause the common cold
meaning that it can be transmitted through costs and sneezes.
And on some of the surfaces that people have touched,
if they have caucus leaves on their hands, that's,
what's making this more scary than any of the other coronavirus outbreaks that
we've dealt with in the past.
This is something that transmits very efficiently in the community.
And that's why this is spreading to many, many different countries.
And it's not really a containable virus because of how easy it's spread and the
fact that many people have mild symptoms that are indistinguishable from the
cold and they're out there doing things and spreading this around. So.
That really the number one problem,
that there are probably many people that have this right now and they simply
don't know. So then they are going to the supermarket, put their hand on,
you know, right by the cash register or something or payment processor.
And then next thing you know, they're transmitting.
That's part of the issue. We know that this virus emerged in China,
at least around mid November,
which meant that it had been spreading probably for some time in the community.
And we didn't, there was no restrictions or anything like that.
People were traveling all over.
So we know that this seeded many countries probably before we even knew knew it.
And we had a pretty severe flu season and because the symptoms are
indistinguishable and most people have mild cases,
they were probably mixed in and not even diagnosed.
And there likely are many undiagnosed chains of transmission in the United
States that are starting to pop up. Now, like we saw in Washington state,
for example, and that's the issue is that we didn't know who had this disease.
So we couldn't tell them, you need to isolate yourself and protect,
protect yourself from infecting others.
Nobody did any of that in the early stages of this outbreak.
And that's what we're left with now.
Obviously in some unchartered territory with coronavirus and our plan here is to
help you make as much sense of the situation in a not alarmist fashion as
possible.
If you're looking for reliable information from experts on the front lines of
the pandemic, check out our Corona virus playlist,
which we'll keep adding updates to right over here and to get notified of all
future videos, be sure to subscribe.